um
okay let's put this over here
can everyone hear me
[Music]
oh you can hear me
good good
we're gonna wait for some more people to
enter the chat before i begin
take off my glasses because i want to
glare
all right then so let's see
see actually let me see if i can go here
this is coffee today
thanks for asking
all right looks like we have some people
flooding in
perhaps um
somebody can link in discord that'd be
great as well
and then we can begin
what i want to discuss
so i suppose i'll start now because i
don't want this video to be super long
although it probably will be considering
that i rant quite a bit
um
well i can sit down
so first off
uh
everyone uh i've actually missed all of
you
for quite some time
um
believe it or not i know some of you
probably think i don't think about you
but in fact i actually miss all of you
quite a bit
i miss speaking with you and one of the
reasons that i'm doing this is so i can
have a an excuse to talk to all of you
um
that said i also wanted to make this
stream because i needed to
discuss some very important matters
relating to this channel
as well as what i've been doing recently
and also to clarify
some other issues
[Music]
so
firstly
for those of you
who may have noticed already
i have released a quite lengthy
uh article refuting allegations against
yakin institute for islamic research
an institute that i am a part of uh as
an unpaid fellow
these accusations these allegations were
brought against the institute
by a certain individual who all of you
are aware of
at this point
and uh for over a year or so i have been
seeing these false allegations and um
i i responded to them briefly in in on
social media and things but i never gave
it any sincere
uh discussion serious discussion
so i decided finally i was going to put
an end to it
and i put all my talents and abilities
into rebutting those accusations
now
as a result of this
i believe a lot of you were quite upset
with me i noticed that in the chats in
the comments many people were upset the
fact that i had responded
and it was actually quite shocking um
it was quite shocking to me
um
[Music]
that that this occurred
because for the longest time a lot of
these same individuals
were
celebrating
daniel's
constant barrage
of attacks and criticisms against the
institute that i worked for and not once
that i see
a lot of you no offense
defend my honor or the honor of my peers
yet
when i
put the burden on myself to defend my
honor in the honor of my peers
mostly them
um
[Music]
i'm
i'm told that i've done something wrong
and to me
it's just it's quite it's very much
unacceptable that individuals have this
sentiment because as muslims we have a
right to defend our honor and our
reputations
and i think that the article that i've
written uh
fully proves that we have been
dishonored and we have been slandered
quite a bit i think anyone who even goes
to the summary of findings will see very
clearly some of the more egregious
errors
that were committed
against us um
some of you need to stop actually
commenting please
uh moderate the comment section i don't
want any sort of vulgar commentary in
here
thank you
uh
so
one of the other responses that i've
seen
[Music]
is that we should not focus on these
lies this is uh this dishonesty because
what's more important is what yakini
institute has apparently done
but i question that logic because it's
extremely illogical
so
if somebody's been lying about what
you're doing why is it that we have to
take responsibility for what they're
lying about
so just recently i uploaded a section
onto the paper
proving conclusively that the keen
institute does not affiliate with
counter countering violent extremism
programs in the united states or
elsewhere
are we do not affiliate with
or receive funding or anything of the
sort from these organizations
from government uh
government and or you know
anti-extremism initiatives okay
and yet
still this is being used against us and
we're not being told that no stop
focusing on the lies
well what else am i supposed to focus on
because if they're lies
why should i take responsibility
or why should we take responsibility why
should anyone take responsibility for
what somebody has lied about
right that doesn't make any sense that's
completely
unjust unwarranted
so you know the issue is the lies the
issue is the dishonesty because the
dishonesty is what's
promoting this view
a view that none of the people institute
behaviors and views that none of the
people yuking institute actually hold to
so why should ya keen institute and
fellows take responsibility now this is
not to say of course that your king
institute is flawless or perfect by no
means
uh there are there are things that we
always have to work on because we're
humans right as human beings allah made
us fallible right so we're going to make
mistakes everyone does
but
um we should not take responsibility for
things we haven't done
and we certainly should not take
responsibility
for lies made against us by an
individual who does not take
responsibility for anything
okay that that's just that's just insane
um please block anyone who is
uh speaking ill in this manner saying
all these vulgar things
or curse words etc this is not that sort
of discussion nor will it ever be
so please ban them properly
i do not want to have to click to the
chat to do that myself thank you
um
okay
i suppose i have to though
i did not like doing this
because
how did it do
when else reports done okay cancel
anyways
where was i okay so
so i'm gonna hide people there we go
um
so where was i i'm sorry about that
and so i took the time to write this
refutation purely for the sake of
defending um
the honor of those who were maligned
unjustly
and
for the sake of truth and for also the
sake of your benefit for everyone's
benefit
who follows my work and just in general
okay and that's why i was also quite
shocked by people who are upset by it
because i was trying to show you that
how you should
analyze and understand propaganda
um how you should be able to critically
think and examine things right that was
one of the point you know to try to
to in to increase the standards of our
discourse
you know we should not be
complicit in this sort of behavior we're
muslims integrity should be the highest
one of the highest virtues that we hold
as an ummah
and as individuals i mean this is this
is
indisputable
i mean in order to advance truth we have
to to submit to truth we have to respect
truth correct
and if we completely throw away those
principles and we say no dishonesty is
okay
because i don't like that person over
there or i don't like that institute
then you've just completely fallen off
the manhattan
okay or you've fallen off the proper
methodology
of dawa okay
that
that's what we need to understand here
that's what i was trying to help
everyone understand
and even in that paper i gave an olive
branch you know just apologize repent
for your sins and we can go back to
doing that like we're supposed to do and
of course that was never
taken and it's unfortunate
um
someone please ban hank i'm gonna do it
now myself okay this is ridiculous
okay
now
in that same paper that i advise all of
you to read at least in part um
i at the end i advise myself because of
all of the damage that's been done right
now within the dallas in all the
corruption the poison the cancer that's
seeping through the dallas scene right
now this this lack of integrity the
methods of islamophobia the methods of
islamophobes for goodness sake
i'm seeing muslims utilizing the same
methods as robert spencer david wood etc
spread islam
okay
this is disgusting
and i no longer want to be a part of
that
[Music]
and i guess one of the other reasons
um
oh god these individuals are really
horrible human beings
um
these individuals
are
um
[Music]
are sort of corrupting our dawah they're
corrupting the message of islam
through these dishonest tactics
likewise there's this perception now
in dawa that speaking and saying it like
it is is somehow more beneficial than
simply speaking the truth as it should
be spoken and what i mean by that is it
says being blunt and callous and coarse
is somehow more beneficial but it's not
it's not at all
okay omar you need to do your job or i'm
going to give somebody else moderator
privileges okay
because there are too many trolls trying
to say very vulgar things and it's
interrupting
uh this discussion please okay
so as i was saying um one of the reasons
that i undertook this project
yeah i hid their their messages
one of the reasons that i undertook this
project was also because i felt
responsible
for what's been going on
for the past 10 or so years
i have contributed to this very toxic
atmosphere
um i provided the soil
for which a lot of these individuals now
are growing from and gaining influence
by
and i felt that it was
my responsibility to finally set it
right to redeem myself
by
removing myself from the scene but at
the same time sending a final message
so it was also my my own form of
repentance
okay
so this will be my final reputation um
that said
um
[Music]
what solidified
my decision even more was what i've seen
in the past few days
[Music]
what i've seen in the past few days on
twitter
disgust me beyond
description
i keep seeing individuals
saying things like
well we're allowed to do these things
because they're insulting the prophet
sallallahu alaihi we send him
and although we should feel pain and
and anguish at the fact that
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
is
is insulted and degraded
um
[Music]
you know the fact of the matter is
that we have to be just in the way that
we deal with people
and what i mean by that is that we only
go after the perpetrators
of those things we don't go after
innocent people around them to make a
point
okay
and i don't want people to take this
analogy the wrong way but i'm trying to
teach a lesson here i'm not saying that
the person the people who are doing this
are like the person i'm about to mention
okay but what i'm trying to say is i'm
trying to prove them and showcase how
the mentality is is dangerous
if we adopt this mentality that it's
okay for us to attack other people's
loved ones because our loved ones were
attacked
in many ways we're justifying the logic
of people like osama bin laden
who himself said that
we're allowed to kill
innocent men women and children because
they're killing our women and children
okay
and that
we can't adopt that principle we have to
be just in all things that we do
we should only go after the individual
who has been unjust not attack people
around them to make a point and if we
want to make the point of free speech we
want to make the point of of how things
should be balanced and you know things
like this
um
then
what we need to do is simply say that we
need to make it that is we need to
suggest as an example
in an abstract manner we don't we don't
go and attack those people to make that
point because that's being unjust we say
hey how would you feel how would you
react if somebody did this to your wife
or your kids or your aunt and your
uncles and your parents etc right we
don't go after we don't go attack those
people when they've done nothing right
that's wrong that's not what a muslim is
supposed to do
um
and in many ways you know people are
gonna look at me and say um
hey you know
aren't you kind of hypocritical because
you've done a lot of things in the past
and you know although i've never done to
this extent but yes you would be correct
in many ways that
that if you compare my previous work
with what i'm saying now many things
that i'm saying
um
don't exactly fall in line with that
behavior
right
but with all due respect to those of you
please hear me out you know i'm trying
to reform myself that's why i'm stepping
away from this scene
okay because i no longer can
can justify it i can no longer
um
be complicit in it okay and i'm
effectively canceling myself because i
know that after i i dropped this video
i'm going to be canceled
i've already been canceled by a large
number of people because of the
refutation that i made but i did it all
for the sake of you guys i did it all
for the sake of protecting people's
reputations i did it for the sake of
truth
so i i honestly don't care anymore
because my integrity and my principles
were always higher than than anything
else i of course i've always
felt depressed by the fact that i
couldn't be more influential
uh but now to be honestly i'm over it
i'm over it because i know i don't want
to have my name put next to individuals
who completely violate everything that i
stand for
and i'm sorry if that sounds harsh to
the brothers that you that you enjoy
listening to and learning from
but
i i can't abide by that i just can't
i i just can't abide by
the dishonest tactics the the the
posturing
the the constant showmanship the the you
know the theatrics of of of so-called
combat
online that doesn't even resemble what
real men would do
um just consistent antagonism
and disgusting vulgar you know
commentary
it's it's
there is a cancer
going through the dallas scene right now
and it will be destroyed because of that
there is a cancerous mentality a
cancerous
lack of ethics
that is just filling the hearts
of our brothers and sisters online
so let me just let me let me um
give you an example of why this is
problematic the recent thing on twitter
for example and we'll go back to some
other subjects okay
um
so imagine
you go online on twitter and you want to
be like you know i want to stand for the
dean i want to stand for the huck you
know i want to be blunt with my faith i
don't care what anybody thinks right and
you go out there and you start laughing
you're like haha yeah of course i'm
proud that we killed murtadz yeah blah
blah blah right and you're acting like
you know like you're i'm a lion of allah
you know that's my name but you know
what i mean what i'm saying right
um
what happens when
yeah you're saying this to this this
this arrogant
okay you're saying it to this arrogant
ex-muslim who just talks nonsense about
islam all day and he feels bad and you
know you're
you're showing dominance but what about
the young muslims who are watching this
who are about to leave the faith because
they're confused
and they realize that you're happy about
killing them
what about those individuals did you
ever think about that did you ever think
that maybe there's a sister or a brother
who's suffering who is in doubts and
then they see somebody just
being proud and laughing about the fact
that they might be executed
aren't we supposed to be bringing those
people back to islam but instead we're
more focused on
showing dominance
to other people
i
i can't i can't comprehend this
um
that said
when they also see the fact that we are
engaging in islamophobic tactics when
we're engaging in quote mining and
taking things out of context
and slandering people
our own selves how is it that we can
effectively combat islamophobia
and anti-islam propaganda
i mean aren't we supposed to be showing
the better side of it aren't we supposed
to be saying hey
the reason that islamophobes are wrong
is because they're dishonest people
isn't that the main methodology that i
have utilized since day one of opening
this channel
that i've been like uh remember the
masked arab
apostate prophet sargon of akkad
all these people i've refuted how have i
refuted them
by showing that they are dishonest
with the sources that they are dishonest
in the way that they quote the quran and
the sunnah
that they are dishonest in the way that
they deal with their intellectual
opposition
and wallahi that has been the most
effective means because when somebody is
dishonest you can't trust them
yet
we have muslims now
following
so-called
orthodox
muslims who are apparently on the hack
they're following and promoting the same
tactics
wallahi
somebody please ban these people i'm
going who wants to be a moderator
who can i trust
mokit as well
okay i need you guys to help omar
any any threats to people's lives or
vulgar commentary i want to be those
people to band immediately please okay
i'm tired of having to see this nonsense
okay
thank you i've just moderated three
people so have fun
um
so anyways the paper is there as an
example
to show you how we should be conducting
ourselves it's my last example to all of
you
it's my redemption
it's it's my
farewell present
in many respects now that doesn't mean
that i'm necessarily going away forever
obviously i'm just i'm just leaving the
refutation scene
um i will still be teaching i'll still
be writing articles i'll still be making
some videos you know things like this
for your benefit but i'm just i'm
distancing myself completely
from this culture
i don't want to be part of i don't care
anymore
if they want to put me on a podcast
if they want to you know invite me to
events if they want to cancel me all
together that is fine because i would
rather they cancel me than suffer my
reputation any further
and suffer my principles any further
well
i i'm sorry i love these brothers
for the sake of allah
but i do not love what they're doing
and i no longer want to be poisoned by
it
okay i've been poisoned enough by the
rhetoric of atheists next muslims for
over a decade i don't need to now from
my own brothers and sisters well i don't
need that
okay
please ban world citizen
and islamic clarity ban him as well
yes even refuting
non-muslims
so
um please been awesome dude as well
and ban world citizen thank you
i want to ban everyone in here trying to
spread this toxic nonsense i don't need
this
we don't need this we need to be upping
our game we should be upping our
standards here okay this is the purpose
of this discussion i i wanted to
initially make this sort of like lecture
video kind of explaining things but i've
decided that that that is not um
i i want to be more personal with you
guys so i think this is a better uh
format
okay
thank you very much
um
so
i i also have some other personal issues
in my life not issues but things going
on in my life which are also prompting
me from
prompting me to leave this scene
entirely
for those of you who have read the paper
i kind of gave some clues
aside from the fact that i want to
better myself and sort of
bury myself in studying the quran and
the hadith
but at the same time i'm also going to
be a father very soon insha allah
and that sort of also helped me to kind
of give me a wake-up call
that you know
if i truly stand for integrity and honor
and things like this this is something
that i want to teach my own children i
want to be exemplars for
and i can't do that
in this
it doesn't work that way
um
so i'm asking all of you please to
sincerely read what i've
written
and
to
please
understand where i'm coming from
and please
please
value integrity and honor above all
things in the matter of discourse and
intellectual
intellectualism
because that those are the things that
we as muslims should be exemplifying
more than anyone
in the world
um
and if we really wanted to honor the
islamic tradition if we want to honor
our scholars we want to honor of course
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the most and the quran
we need to we need to uphold these
principles beyond everything else
and i'm sorry you know it sounds like a
character from somebody who is not
worthy of giving one
and your you be correct in many respects
i'm not a credible scholar i'm not a
credible anything i'm just an academic a
student of knowledge
but i know this to be true and i know it
because of what the scholars have said
i know because that's what the quran and
sunnah teach is that you do not mix
truth with falsehood
and i have stuck to that even in my own
vulgarities in my own uh
mockery my own you know childish
displays that i've done over the years
my own uh
egoism it i know for a fact that at very
least that i've stuck to those
principles of honor and integrity
and those are the things that i'm taking
with me when i leave
but i wanted you all to adopt those
things and discard everything else about
me that i have
that i have taught you
over the years
so
for those of you
um so i guess that's really what i
wanted to say to be honest
the paper is is linked on twitter it's
on my blog actually
as well it's linked on twitter it's
linked in the community chat on my
youtube page
i just updated it today with the cve
section
i'll be updating
with more sections in the future
i have the lgbt section to update soon
and then two other ones in the shadia
section
um
so i guess uh before leaving i don't
want to make this too long i suppose i
just want to kind of open the floor for
questions about that paper specifically
um about you know
how to navigate it if you want what you
know
what should be looked for
uh if you have any questions
specifically about what was written
therein
um i'm feel free to ask and i'll answer
those questions
um
also you know um
or anything else for that matter if you
guys just want to talk you know i can
give another 30 minutes or so just to
have a discussion
um
so
i believe the stream will be left up yes
certainly please ask
oh
perhaps i'll i'll look at the questions
but let me um
um
let me be let me talk about this
reputation culture um it's it's never
been
flawless it's never been perfect by any
means but i think it's become worse than
it's ever been
uh like i said i've been over here in
this culture for over a decade and i've
never seen it this bad
and i remember the first time that i was
invited to it that i was invited into
the culture that was invited into this
dallas scene
this form of dawah
and it was by brother abdullah in delusi
and abdullah has always been for me
one of the greatest examples
of
adept
and um
intellectualism on this medium on not
only just youtube and social media but
in general as a daily
i have respected him
for that alone
uh i have such a great respect for that
alone
hums of sorts is also comes to mind he's
a good man
we disagree on a bit and there are times
that i'm to be frank with you i've been
kind of upset at him but that's a
different story it's it's quite petty
actually
but
i cannot say anything bad about hamza in
terms of his adap in his his his
sincerity
um
and i love them for the sake of allah i
love them for the sake of allah and i
wish
they weren't being drowned out right now
that their work wasn't being spit on
by
by individuals who in their naivety
and their
i wouldn't even say zealousness because
to me it's not zealousness it's it's
it's it's
it's a facade of zealousness
and their posturing
are are just kind of stepping over
everything that has been done
[Music]
so
you know it upsets me it accepts me
quite a bit
and um it's just i'm done now i've
literally everything that i used to feel
bad about
has been replaced by something else and
what i mean by that is initially
i thought there was something i failed
this this community because
i wasn't doing it right i wasn't doing
dowel right
but it wasn't that i failed for a
different reason i failed because i did
not correct
a lot of the bad elements that were
seeping in and i did not correct myself
fast enough
my own behavior my own lack of adept
that it birthed
it created the soil for for for
for other things to grow
that's where i failed
that's that's really where i failed
and i'm very sorry
i'm very sorry
um
[Music]
and i ask all of you for you know for
forgiveness
for not
dealing with it sooner for being too
worried about my own influence instead
of
worrying about
the type of influence
i was actually giving
and that is my fault
and now i am trying to correct it
before leaving so that i can
[Music]
do
you know
give a greater benefit to this ummah
from a different place
somewhere else
so
i suppose that's really it um
i don't want to be talking for too long
but
essentially my goals after all of this
after i'm finished writing and
publishing this stuff
i intend to continue working with your
keen institute for islamic research
i continued to work on myself and
study
under a check
[Music]
and i just continue writing articles and
hopefully inshallah doing lectures and
and trying to help the youth
outside of social media i'll probably
also be dropping off social media
um
almost entirely i'll probably keep my
facebook
and the youtube channel obviously but
only post things that i'm doing outside
uh until i have some good news coming
with respect to one of my papers on my
blog
that was initially independent i think
you guys are aware of it it was a paper
that i wrote not too long ago about
science in the quran
that is now going to be officially
published for you insha'allah after some
editing
so
you know hopefully that will that will
be a benefit to many more people
um
so and as you can probably tell also i'm
very tired
um look at my eyes you know my beard is
completely almost gray now
i haven't been sleeping much for the
past two weeks
i've been getting like four hours of
sleep every day because i'm working and
also working on this reputation at the
same time
so that's not good for my health
no i'm not going to re-upload that video
because i don't think it's necessary
uh yeah i do want to redo understanding
atheism series
i think that that would be good
this channel is going to be
about
now it's going to be less about
refutations and it's going to be more
about
teaching muslims how to think
teaching muslims how to read
teaching muslims how to perceive things
without necessarily having to attack
people
um i know that was a interesting and fun
method at one point and i jihad is still
something that i really want to play
with
but i i think it's going to be less
involved with the refutation culture
than it used to be entirely actually
um
uh
to do
so what else
yes i mean
just look at your keen institute and
stuff like this i mean i of course
social media is the primary means of
communication these days unfortunately
so that's why i'll be posting everything
that i do
anytime that i upload a lecture or
something of that sort i'll do it here
obviously
but i may start deleting certain things
i may start to get rid of certain things
because i just don't feel that i want to
um
i don't want to be attached to a former
identity of this that this channel had
um
yeah so
i'll probably teach more philosophy
from an islamic perspective um as an
authority
um
you know i khalifa videos would be great
i can continue doing those
right now i'm just very tired so um i
don't really know what's going to happen
i'm actually exhausted
uh spiritually emotionally mentally i'm
just very tired
i want to take i i don't even want to do
anything to be honest
so
but
i do have an obligation to all of you
i have an obligation to this to this
ummah and i have an obligation of course
first and foremost to allah
and our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
so i must keep with that obligation my
duty as a muslim
um
inshallah
the baby it's still very early
so we're
you know
but
um inshallah hopefully be february and
march
so um it's like i said it's very early
okay but inshallah it'll
that's what the baby will be do we've
already picked out names i'm not gonna
tell you
but uh when we when when it gets later
on then inshallah maybe i'll reveal what
the names are
depending on the gender of course
thank you so much
my views on politics i don't like
politics
i don't involve myself with politics
i already have enough to think about
um
thank you
i don't i'm still going to be affiliated
with mdi and don't worry about it it's
fine um you're okay
i'll still be in philly with mdi because
i stand for what abdullah al-andalusi
and zara forest and all of them do
i think that they are they should be
they should be at the forefront of this
scene of this refutation culture
actually
um they should be the ones leading it
not not many individuals that i'm
currently seeing
uh and that i've engaged with
that are considered to be the most
popular not
um they in fact
have everything that that the muslims
need
uh
within this particular culture and i
think that they should be lauded as the
as the leaders of this of this of this
sort of data
unfortunately they've been sidelined
and overshadowed by
individuals who
get people's attention based on
entertainment value based on
entertainment based on bombastic
displays of you know theatrics
it seems like our youth are more um
more prone to enjoying
and you know
callousness
and mockery
which is unfortunate
uh
yes i do believe the pragmatic approach
can can be very beneficial which is
something that i'll be writing about
later from the perspective of even
payment
in the meantime for those of you who
want to read up on hypnia's epistemology
with respect to atheism and belief in
god i think that you should go to the
keen institute for islamic research the
website and look up one of our most
recent uh articles on ebentami's
epistemology by uh dr nazar khan
he it's a very lengthy article very
erodic
chock full of facts
about how epidemia perceived
epistemology and especially with respect
to belief in god
so
i will not
i'm not here to
speak of the intentions of anyone
necessarily i'm here to say that the
methods are incorrect according to quran
and sunnah
as far as i'm aware
there's and i see no good evidence you
know bringing up abu bakr's one-time
rebuttal to somebody is not evidence
that this is a common standard practice
that we should engage in nor
is it in any way shape or form
justification for attacking people's
loved ones
um
you know and i find it actually to be
frank an indirect insult to abu bakr
himself
to one of the companions stuff law so i
mean i don't think it was intentional by
any means but you know it is quite
insulting to compare what you're doing
on twitter with what abu bakr has done
[Music]
welcome
the best way to counter islamophobia is
to have integrity
because the achilles heel of
islamophobes is their lack of integrity
if you if you reveal their dishonesty
with islamic source material and
and scholarship then you can undermine
them quite easily
but if we adopt their tactics then
that's not going to happen
right especially you know it's quite
it's quite ironic considering the fact
that we are opposed to this idea that we
that we um that we're doing takiyah
and yet we have muslims who are actively
doing
what islamophobes think we do with each
other
it's it's quite sad
one can expose inconsistencies without
without
being unjust
right i mean like i mentioned earlier
you could just bring it up as an example
in this abstract way you don't have to
actually perform that
thing itself like if somebody
you know
hurt my family i'm not going to hurt
their family and be like see i'm just
proving a point no that's wrong
i have a couple more minutes guys
we're going to have more talks in the
future inshallah but just just not like
this
this is coffee actually um
this is a macchiato yes i'm very fancy
i'm just making a comparison an analogy
i still do want to make the chrysler
shooting but i think that i'm going to
turn it into more of an academic
exercise
um one where
i will reveal conclusively that robert
smith one of the reasons that robert
spencer hates me so much is not even so
much that i point out his is cowardice
and with respect to debate and his
inability to
to
fulfill his agreements
but he's upset with me because he knows
for a fact that i found out
not just found out that i can
[Music]
logically
factually connect his ideas to christ
church that's one of the other reasons
that he does not like me very much
yes i've had turkish tea i like it very
much i like all tea
for the most part
yes at one point i
did
when that individual actually went after
me personally
and then i promptly deleted after she
stopped
see but i did not just go on attacking
people just because i wanted to prove a
point
so you have to understand we
islam we only go after those who are
unjust we don't go after
people around them
to hurt that person okay that doesn't
make any sense that's not what we're
supposed to be doing
like
if that's the case yes
you know like i said
but this is not
we're not
what happened on twitter and this is the
last time i'm gonna talk about it was
not just
okay well this woman
also says this so we're gonna go after
her no
it was everyone affiliated with those
individuals to prove a point that you're
not supposed to attack somebody's loved
ones
okay that was the problem
so even if we even if we concede to the
fact that one of them is not innocent it
doesn't mean the other ones
it somehow makes it justified okay do
you see what i'm saying like this is
th this is this is the point that i'm
trying to make here because
it was never established that
all of those people who were attacked
were somehow
guilty
all right and i know of one of them who
definitely was not guilty
she didn't deserve any sort of that
embarrassing harassment or any other
such thing so i'm not gonna even go into
this
um
okay so let's stop trying to justify
this okay you have no justification from
quran and sunnah for this at all
all right so i'm not going to even
entertain this discussion any further
once again let me let me bring up a more
extreme example
but you know like i said the same the
person who used that same
logic
to kill innocent people was osama bin
laden he even used a lot of the sources
that are being used online
to make this argument okay
so let's stop
this is wrong
okay it doesn't matter
quran also says that we should we should
still have justice and we should not let
our aversion to people our hatred of
people to be unjust we should not have
that be a cause of us being unjust
right it doesn't matter how much you
hate somebody
it doesn't mean we'd be unjust with them
okay we are muslims we are not those
people they are disgusting people
these murtadin that are on here trying
to make a name for themselves because
they hate islam they are disgusting
human beings they will be fueled for the
fire inshallah
unless of course they repent obviously
right
but right now
they deserve their they not to be
respected however however we
respect our deen we respect our
principles we respect islam we respect
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
okay we do not
interpret our deen based on their
behavior
correct
call us
to it to tackle extreme western
supremacy
to destroy western hegemony to destroy
secular liberal
ideology that's overcoming the muslim
world today not just in the west not
just among muslim minorities
right but among every muslim on the
planet now it's there's a hegemony over
us that we
places like bangladesh pakistan
uae
you know other places liberal secular
liberalism is taking over okay which is
why i find a passing why why so many
people in southeast asia or in asian
countries are so fascinated with the
aquino institute in criticizing what
we're doing here
because you know you have your own
problems
uh much bigger ones in many respects
but anyways um
you know the re the way to tackle this
is first we have to become independent
from these ideas we have to become
independent in such a way that we don't
need to latch ourselves to the west
we have so many rich muslims for example
who do not invest in science or
education and other such things you know
uh muslims and culturally in many places
in the world only want certain
professions for their children engineers
doctors lawyers business people
well we need to also be focused on the
humanities like librarianship
you know things like this
we need to be able to become
self-sustainable
right
if we really want to break away we first
need to actually take practical steps
towards doing that and we have to
cultivate an intellectual culture
based on integrity and honor to our
sources and to facts
that's how we're going to defeat
secularism secular liberalism is a
reactionary ideology that only destroys
okay
it only destroys to free people from
their shackles
and if we adopt a reactionary approach
we're only allowing liberalism to come
in and take over
you cannot destroy your reactionary
ideology through reactionarianism or i
mean that's a word through being
reactionary right that that doesn't make
any sense
it's going to be a long process
it's going to be long long time
but this what we're doing now this
culture this reputation culture that we
have now
is is going to be the end of us is going
to be the end of dollar
i do not care look i'm going to be frank
with you i don't care about the feelings
of these of these popular murtadin i
don't care
wallahi i don't care they can you know
piss off excuse my french okay
i care about those young muslims who
have doubts who are watching this
and are going to leave islam because of
it
that's what i'm concerned with
okay that's what i'm concerned with
because those those are the people we
should be worried about not the people
who are so full of themselves who have
such huge egos who are narcissists
who who know who the arrogant ones that
allah speaks about in the quran that
will be fueled for the hell fire okay
whatever
i'm talking about the people whose
hearts can still be softened i'm talking
about the people who still have an open
mind who are watching
us
just playing around acting like it's
it's funny to kill people
uh stuff for a lot that we're proud of
it
we should not be proud of punishing
people what is this
what is this
okay
my method has already been has always
been really balanced when you see people
mocking the prophet
the first thing you need to ask is if
they're ignorant
in ignorance many people can say stupid
things
there's a difference between being
extremely arrogant and just ignorant and
and foolish
and of course people can be both as well
but
legitimately i have actually turned
people
away from doing that
by approaching them with with compassion
and peace and showing them facts
and then there are people who you have
to rebut in a harsh manner in order to
protect the dean of others okay
but you have to be strategic you have to
be practical in many ways as well you
can't just like
just
descend upon them with these vulgarities
you have to also consider the audience
because remember it's not about
whenever i rebutted and refuted a lot of
these these ex-muslims right and
islamophobes i didn't do it because i
wanted to destroy them per se
but because i wanted to show muslims who
were doubt who had who had doubts about
their from watching their videos and
reading their articles etc
i wanted them to see that these people
could not be trusted
so if i just engaged in posturing and
just trying to belittle these people
like i don't think it would be as
effective now of course i sprinkle in
some
little quips and stuff for for good
entertainment and
you know but i don't i don't
that's not the substance of my of my
methodology
and it shouldn't be anybody's
okay
so i just go back to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam right and
once again i'm speaking to myself when i
say these things to you all
take after his example he was extremely
calm
in the face of insult excuse me my
apologies
and yes we should have a giraffe for the
prophet salallahu
and for our religion
but we also have to follow his example
correct i mean that's the part of
following the sunnah right right
so when we have this gear we also have
to consider look what would the prophet
saw allah do in this in this
circumstance
and if you read the syria of the prophet
sallallahu whatever you know he's a very
balanced person he does not
react the same to everyone
right he doesn't he he gauges that
person's character he gauges that person
like what that person is trying to do he
gauges their he like he tries to see
like what age they are are they a young
person or the old person uh what sort of
beliefs do they hold uh what's their
demeanor how have they acted in the past
how are they acting now he measures
everything before he makes his reaction
right he doesn't just like
he didn't just blurt things out
he didn't just say the same thing to
everyone
some people he would tell them even
different advice depending on that
person's
characteristics he wouldn't give the
same answer to everyone
correct
so we have to be the same way and of
course this is a very nuanced approach
and we have dies now who are claiming
that nuance is an excuse now
let's be frank of course there are
certain academics who use the nuance
card to make excuses but not all of them
do
and when we talk about nuance we should
always see that as a very as mostly a
positive word
because reality is not simple it's
complex
our circumstances are complex the way
that we live is complex the way that we
perceive things is complex
nuance is not a bad word in fact nuance
is the enemy of islamophobes because
they rely on oversimplifying things they
rely on memes they rely on their
audience only seeing things in black and
white and just very simple terms
that's why they're so effective the same
way with trump and modi and all of these
corrupt politicians who are frankly
idiots beyond a shadow of a doubt and
evil to the core
but they command such a wide audience
because they tell it like it is in
simple terms
they they tell you what you want to hear
instead of what you need to hear
right same thing with yakin institute
we're trying to tell you what you need
to hear
based on the nuances of the tradition
whereas there are certain individuals
who are trying to tell you just what you
want to hear
okay once again
no side is perfect
but i'm trying to make
a point
okay and the scholars in general look
even if you don't like your keen
institute let's forget this for a moment
the greatest scholars of old they wrote
volumes of works
volumes on the most simple things but
they made
they were so eroding they
they they they looked at every single
angle of every ayah of every hadith
of the sunnah okay
they wrote huge volumes of works the fic
tradition is defined by its nuance and
yet we have people out there
saying oh nuance is an excuse mental
gymnastics
what stuff for the law
what have we become
seriously
what are we becoming
so i'm gonna i guess i'm just gonna keep
ranting if i keep going like this
[Music]
um
what do i do
to work out
oh you're gonna
so a lot of people don't know this about
me i've said it i've talked about it a
couple times but
um
okay so
i was in i i was a
amateur fighter for some time so i went
to the the uh
you know the youth olympics for
taekwondo things like this
um
and i was like a national champion and
things like this and then of course i
got hurt some of you who watch my
biography video you'll know that
i was i was hurt quite badly and
told not to fight again so um
but i need to keep up with that
i still love martial arts i still train
but i train in a different way
shortly after um
rehabilitating my body
um
i started to find comfort and uh in a
different form of exercise that i really
really enjoyed
um
and having grown up at kind of a bad
part of town as well i was always into
hip-hop
music
so i became a break dancer
believe it or not there's some videos of
me out there dancing
um
and um
yeah i actually still break dance to
this day
in private or at a park where most
people can't see me
but i still practice my moves and stuff
because it's actually a lot of exercise
um
so uh yeah i know it's funny but i
actually can do break dancing
um
so
yeah uh so it's actually a huge workout
if you guys you wouldn't believe how
much strength it takes to be and i'm not
as good as i used to because i'm older
now you know
but yeah it's it's a it's a workout you
don't really need weights now i do go to
the weight room occasionally
um to work on
like my chest and stuff and i've i've
really been slacking the past few months
i gained a lot of weight that i need to
lose down in the stomach area so i'm
trying to work on that get back
into form but um
but generally that's what i do so
yeah
no i'm not going to show you an example
i'm wearing a thobe
inshallah i'm writing a book
i don't know much about islamabad or
pakistan to be honest with you
and breaking in a though would break my
leg
probably
so
i take three sugars in my coffee i have
a pretty bad sweet tooth my wife is like
the opposite of me she loves spicy food
like crazy
so
which is why we both like malay food
interestingly enough because malay food
is both sweet and spicy so
i do like sports when i was younger i
played baseball a little bit and of
course martial arts was my main one
i am not super fit right now
you know to be frank with you when i
watched that debate the first time
between wood and hijab i actually
believe that wood
deserved
because he's
it's it's actually difficult for me to
to actually
judge
even though i feel that he deserved it
at the same time i'm conflicted because
he is legitimately a psychopath
right he can't control
that behavior
so in a way it's like i don't i'm kind
of conflicted
but yeah i do consider him generally to
be a detestable human being
um
yeah
can i say pakistan zindabad yes i can
say pakistan's into bed
kuhn is my favorite philosopher
um
yes uh most of my work is going to be
not most of it but a lot of my work is
going to be focused on science
and philosophy
and sort of also tackling the the
science in the quran
you know dawa
it's almost no it's already over an hour
hmm
yes christian apologists have been
taking advantage of the oscar claudia's
comments for quite some time and we're
feeling the fire by um insisting that
they're correct
uh by attacking us our claudia so much
in fact he's he was a you know we we
have been disparaging him for quite some
time
this this community and it's quite sad
despite whatever mistakes he has made
he's also done quite a bit of good and
we treat him like he's a worse enemy
than people like robert spencer are
and then we tried to justify it on the
basis that oh we need to we need to get
rid of all these you know deviants in
our community that's the big issue right
now it's like well first off you need to
establish deviancy and not simply
because of a secondary thing that a
secondary issue or something like if you
if you're going to establish that
somebody is deviant because
they have an opinion about gog and magog
that isn't found in the quran and sunnah
but isn't also explicitly mentioned as
being opposed to quran and sunnah then
you know there's something wrong with
your deen or your understanding of your
deen more than
what
that person is saying just being frank
um you know we're picking
we have a community of nitpickers
going around trying to literally going
through hours of videos and articles
trying to find something we can call
somebody deviant for that's that's a
disease of the heart
okay that i'm gonna be frank with you
i am an author yes i am authority by
creed
inshallah i'll get rest one day
a good book ibn rajab anything written
by ibn rajab if you can find translated
it would be is great for the soul i've
been reading a lot of ibm
humbly
he's been really helping me especially
his commentary on the 40 hadith of imam
nalae
it was is that is that correct yes i
believe it is
uh
i'm not 30 because it makes the most
sense
and yes it is very pragmatic but i don't
it's not i don't adopt it because it's
pragmatic necessarily it's beneficial
for that sake but yeah but
no you're not blocked wolfgang
miss you brother
i'm hoping to speak with you very soon
by the way
uh regarding some things about the
article
i do not like sony or i mean i like them
but i don't own a sony or
microsoft system because i don't really
care for them
i'm a nintendo fan
i believe
let me see
i'm not against the ashari in mataris i
mean look there are a lot of traditional
scholars who adopted either one of those
positions and i don't disparage them
may allah forgive them for any of their
mistakes
and sins and likewise forgive me
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna cancel
scholars because of things like that i'm
sorry i just can't
um and i don't understand why other
people do um like you know ibn rush for
example like i i quote him quite a bit
when it comes to thick because he was a
master of vic
right
and there are people telling me oh but
he believed in aristotelian you know
philosophy kalam it's like yeah okay but
he was still
a master of fick
right i'm not going to throw away the
diet
because
he believed in heresytillianism
um
oh i love dragon ball z back in the day
i was always a big fan of vegeta he's
always the best character on the show
i'm happy that adam saleh is
mending divides but at the same time i
don't i mean with the
the health of the reputation culture
right now he's coming in at a very bad
time
so i'd actually tell him to kind of like
not engage because
it might actually even be worse for him
at this point
or at least engage
in a different like kind of from a
distance
i like you know my favorite anime was um
tri-gun it's only 23 episodes or
something but it's one of the most
amazing animes you'll ever see in your
life so watch it
dragon ball super was good too
uh especially the last fight
the last episode was like it made the
entire series i'm sorry
my view on evolution
uh of course i believe that adam is
completely separate the adamic line the
line that we come from
is completely separate but i am also
willing to believe that hominids or
creatures that are like us existed side
by side and then became extinct um
i don't know
if that's true or not
but i don't see it conflicting with the
quran and sunnah as long as i believe
that adam
of course was specially created and that
we only came from his line so that's my
position
i held a mistaken position prior to this
from my misunderstanding of genetics and
genealogy and it was a very simple
mistake and i apologize for having it
but at no point did i i think the main
problem was that i didn't sincerely
analyze that belief
because i really didn't i don't really
engage too much
with evolution unless i'm using it to
support certain positions like for
example
i utilized evolutionary theory to defend
aisha being nine years old and mature at
the at that age
um but of course that didn't have
anything to do with common ancestry so i
never really questioned it until
recently like a couple months back i was
talking to
when i was writing this reputation i
actually started reading more of um
dr jalagel's views and he gives a number
of views possibilities and the more that
i read from him and kind of discussed
with him i came to the realization that
my prior position was actually
not the most um
correct one
to put it lightly
so i kind of switched and i realized
that there was other options so i took
that option
so that's why that's why i said on
twitter that he helped me because he did
creed is wrong obviously
so you know and also you have to
understand my view of science as well is
um
it's ever-changing so you know
eventually
you know this whole concept of evolution
may be overturned by a different
paradigm so i'm not really attached to
it that much like it doesn't really
affect me
um i don't think that science could ever
find out
you know can ever provide
absolute proof that adam and eve existed
i believe in adam and eve because of the
quran and sunnah i believe in adam and
eve because that makes sense
you know in accordance with our
cohering with our with our perception of
reality
i don't need empirical evidence to
believe in adam and eve
okay and anyone who says that you need
that or that it's even possible i'm
sorry that person
is in error
okay
um
but i mean
okay so let's just remove
common ancestry for a moment guys
because
but adaptation and mutation is is is a
scientific fact
um and there's a lot of things we can
learn from evolutionary theory
so you know you let's not
throw out the baby with the bathwater
okay
like i said i used evolutionary theory
life history theory which is a product
of evolutionary theory
to
showcase that aisha was mature at the
age of nine back then
right so i mean look it can also be
beneficial consider this okay
yeah i think evolution is tends to be
simplified too much
because there's even debates within
evolutionary science i mean i mean if
you read some of these papers like
they're disagreeing with each other all
the time
i mean what darwin believed a lot of
scientists don't believe anymore they
have a completely different
understanding of evolution compared to
what he did
so you have to be very cautious about
how you perceive these things when
people say darwinism i kind of cringe
because it's like
most scientists aren't darwinist
thank you
i haven't really looked into the hadith
literature that much regarding his his
his actual size and you know if that's
what it says then that's what i believe
you know it's it's sound that's what i
believe
yeah i mean actually christians have
kind of made it a bigger deal
i don't know what richard dawkins i
don't even think richard dawkins knows
what he is he doesn't even know where he
is half the time he's on twitter he
can't even he doesn't even know what
he's typing
the guy is almost senile like let's
forget richard dawkins he's old news
so if you really want to
understand evolution from like a very
like um intellectual perspective
uh the late stephen j gould's work
stephen j gould
he was an american scientist who
disagreed with dawkins on a lot of
things and actually dawkins hated him he
was jealous of him
um
gould passed away a long time ago but he
wrote a lot of good work
on the subject
i re i respect subwar ahmed quite a bit
and showed malik by the way who and and
showed was very upset by the way what
happened to the geological dr gelajo
like he respects him profoundly so if
you respect shueid malik
just know that he respects and admires
dr gelagio so don't stand for any
slander against dr gelagil okay that's
if you if you respect joy because he he
won't stand for that just being honest
with you guys
well now we're talking philosophy and
science
i don't know about the building of
pyramids
i don't know any i don't really study
that stuff
take what is good and leave what is bad
but never follow somebody who doesn't
have the integrity to to represent their
opposition as they are and what they
actually believe
and who is not willing to steal man
their arguments
what i mean by steel manning is opposite
of straw manning when you straw man you
build a mischaracterization and
misrepresentation of somebody's
arguments to burn it down
when you steal man you build the
strongest possible
form of their argument and then attack
it because that's what a person with
integrity would
do um
logic is a language
to express the way that we think or
should think rationally
it's not an actual thing in and of
itself
but our intuition is our primary means
of understanding things
i did watch some of that debate yes
i found it to be
quite poor
um
to be frank and i'm not speaking simply
because i have some sort of personal
grudge but i just felt it was a very
poor discussion debate um unbefitting of
either side
well no actually one side no that was
pretty much expected
um because you know one side's an idiot
but the other side you know has a great
deal of education should never engage in
such such a performance
um
well it's easy to expose a simpleton
any simpleton can do that
right
but an educated person should never
really uh
deal with that sort of individual unless
it's an academic platform
as far as i'm i'm concerned now
a steel man is not a fallacy a steel man
is
is not considered fallacious because
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to build their argument trying to
make their argument as strong as
possible like you're playing your own
devil's advocate
okay you're trying to say okay
this person could be wrong about this
but let me give him
the the greatest benefit of a doubt that
he actually meant this because this
seems more logical this seems more to
make more sense and then you destroy
that
and if you destroy the steel man then
you actually win the debate
you actually win the discussion the
argument
but if you destroy the straw man you
haven't won anything
you're just you're just posturing
i don't really care for the muslim
brotherhood whatever political party
do i think a degree in philosophy is
worth it
uh yes
i do um i think it's helpful as long as
you go in knowing that what you're
learning is not absolutely the case
like a lot of people have this
perception that the moment you walk into
like a philosophy 101 class you're going
to lose your your iman
i don't buy that the reason i don't buy
that is because i feel like the people
who do lose their faith when they go
into philosophy have already kind of
gone down that already thinking about
going down that path or already have a
weak understanding of what their
religion is
and also have a weak understanding of
philosophy itself
philosophy 101 course should not
question your faith
because if you go to philosophy 101
you're just learning like basic stuff
that
in more advanced philosophy classes is
largely considered obsolete
or like the discussion has like moved on
you know what i mean like like i've seen
people say well after reading descartes
or reading hume i became an atheist i'm
like why
you know how many people responded to
them since like 100 years or the past
hundred years like really come on like
nobody listens to hume anymore
um it's just ridiculous
uh people insinuating that accusations
made in the article are relevant to the
adversary's points uh no
yeah i've seen the the whole accusation
of nitpicking i find that very
fascinating
considering you know
that
taking people out of context and
committing fallacies isn't nitpicking
you know any degree i mean it's an error
if i was nitpicking i'd be focusing on
typos
and like spelling mistakes you know
things like this
um
but i didn't
i focus on
actual
issues of factual inaccuracy fallacious
reasoning and clear clear cases of
dishonesty
i've discussed that already we're all on
the same topics for some reason let's
get you know i don't really want to talk
about people the reason the only reason
i brought those individuals up in
passing
indirectly is because i wanted to make a
point i'm trying to discuss the problems
of the taoism today i'm not trying to
hurt these people
i only wish the best for these people
and i pray that they just
increase the standards of our of our
discourse okay
so i'm not trying to say that i want
them to go away that i want them to be
canceled
um i just want them to reform themselves
to make it better they have the
abilities the talents to do those things
they shouldn't be engaging in this this
sort of behavior in in in
poor rhetoric
okay that that's my point and i'm not
even saying that i am perfect by any
means that's why i'm doing these things
because i'm redeeming myself
right
i have very upset about people who don't
wear a mask especially in the united
states
you know even if you notice how i dealt
with the master how did i deal with him
yes i put some satire in there some
mockery in some cases but it was only
with respect to certain things he said
and his sort of his arrogant attitude
i didn't like go after his like you know
everything
and i i deconstructed him analyzed him
academically
right i mean that's what if that's the
standard that you want then that's what
we need to be shooting for i'm not going
to be here doing that anymore but if
that's what you want out of dawah then
you need to tell
your dais
these people
to do that
correct you need to to give them nasiha
you need to tell them to advise them
okay let's let's stop promoting this
culture of memory and
vulgarity and disgusting dishonest
tactics
tell them to up their game tell them
that integrity matters above everything
else
not telling it like it is
because if you don't have integrity when
you tell it like it is then you're not
saying
anything right you're you're you're
spitting on the truth
you're undermining the truth
you're lying to people you're deceiving
people
right this is wrong
yeah and where's the master of now right
nowhere
because i stuck to what
integrity
if i played his game do you think that
would have done anything no
you know imagine if i would have
released a video
just strawmatting everything he said and
just trying to like
um
just find any way to win
you know what i mean without any measure
of integrity if he pointed that out i
would have lost all credibility
right
i would have been i would have been
called a muslim who's engaging in
taqiyya
right
do do we not see the danger of this
that's what i'm trying to tell you all
come on think about this
thank you
it's already one oh an hour and 30
minutes
crazy
um my story coming to islam is nothing
exciting i'm sorry
uh it's on my bio
video
it's very simple i just
i was disillusioned with christianity
and i found islam to be more coherent
that was it
yeah a lot of regrets from dallas films
days of course
i conducted myself inappropriately and
many times i was too rambunctious or too
uh impulsive in many respects
i didn't think things through i felt
that i was being zealous but a lot of
times it was my ego and that's why i was
ultimately defeated
because i defeated myself
so when i started this channel i decided
to i was going to go a different route
even then i'm still growing i'm still
trying to better myself so
intel i like to do that i like those
comics they're really fun
uh
goodness me
can't stay too much longer i want to
talk to you guys that's why i'm here
longer because i enjoy speaking with all
of you
at the same time you shouldn't concern
yourself too much with a lot of these
online personalities explosive
personalities because i'm guaranteeing
you right now the reason they do a lot
of this
is because of the misery and depression
that they feel in their real lives
outside of this medium
because of their impotence their social
intellectual impotence in general so
they're trying to project what they want
to be here they act like they're
completely different people online than
they are offline that's something you
need to understand okay a lot of things
that they're doing here
are not things that they do in real life
inshallah please do
please keep up the good fight
thank you
i feel bad for vasim
vasim is very you know i actually think
vasim is actually abdullah samir but
whatever
um you know because he has he has enough
time in his hands to make that account
um
but you know um
but fossum is a different person who's
just like this this this angry child
angry young guy
you know i do wish that he he comes
around and he's guided
but you know if he's going to troll you
know control him back
you know have a little fun with him
uh expose the the hypocrisy and things
like this but do it in such a way that
you're not like going too far right
i think introverted smiles is correct to
drop the explosive label because it's
being utilized
in such a way to advance islamophobia
and i've been saying this for a very
long time so i'm very happy to see that
a lot of ex or some explosives are
finally adopting
this approach because they realize that
they're that they're being used
right like you're being used to go
against muslims
right so you need to just get rid of it
define yourselves by what you believe in
don't define by yourself by what you're
not that doesn't even tell anybody
anything like if i go around saying i'm
a next christian what does that mean
i left christianity okay well what do
you believe i'm an ex-christian well who
cares
i will read those um counter arguments
and evidences later regarding my views
on apostasy punishment
but i just wanted to get that sort of
thing out earlier because i don't want
people to assume that i'm just rejecting
it because i'm some sort of like
reformist liberal or something which is
ridiculous all of you know i've been
fighting against secular liberalism for
like over a decade
okay it's nonsense that somebody would
accuse me of being reformist or a
liberal um
the reason that hara sultan is gaining
popularity in india is because most
of the people who are giving him
popularity are idiots who want to kill
muslims so
it's not hair sultan that's the issue
welcome
any other things we want to talk about
like i said i want to keep talking about
other people because we're sort of also
feeding into this culture remember like
if we keep talking about these guys
look let's talk about
i mean i understand why we're talking
about it numero
because it's sort of the context right
but let's not keep asking the same the
same questions please
one of my plans after the stream to be
honest with you um i have to complete
some other sections on that paper so i'm
going to start maybe tomorrow on that
but in the meantime
after this stream i think i'm going to
play a video game
so
um
the bat that machine in the background
that's my um
inversion table so because remember i
was injured back in the day uh doing
martial arts
so i still have i have arthritis in my
back so i use that to help me
oh i played switch
i don't know what game i'm gonna play
yet
i'm looking i'm i beat paper mario
origami king it was amazing
but uh i still feel like playing it
again for some reason i just liked it
that much
i can still do taekwondo i still
you know every now and then
i'm not a half-head of the quran
how do you improve vocabulary you read
and you write
read and write a lot
don't go on social media and do it read
like actual read books
how to manage my time don't sleep
both the uk and usa dallas scenes are
are offensively crap right now
they need to improve drastically
i'm not talking about every organization
i'm just saying like the scene that we
see on social media that's all bad
there are good actors within that scene
but they're being overshadowed by people
who
aren't minding our principles
i sleep like four to six hours depending
when i go to speaker's corner no because
i don't want to hear people shouting at
me
that's annoying
mario odyssey is amazing
how to manage time
keep a list
uh
understand your limitations
don't overreach
and
best of all be in an environment where
you know for a fact that you are going
to be forced to work
yes i played ocarina of time it's my
first n64 game that i beat
american muslims are not more liberal
than their uk counterparts i guarantee
you that
in fact we make up a much
less significance
number within the america within this
population then uk muslims make in
theirs we're also divided
much more based on land mass
and the amount of sunni muslims in this
country is significantly lower than even
what the number is purported to be so
for example
uh statistics show
that in the united states only one
percent or 1.2 percent of the population
is muslim
but what they count as muslim in
statistics or in the senses
they they count every sect
right so in fact the reality is that
only half of that is actually sunny
okay so actually 0.5
it's more like 0.5 sunni in this country
or even 0.6 at most
um
i have not been to either
i think sam harris is washed up he's a
he's a great sophist but other than that
i mean he has nothing to offer
which i guess means he has nothing to
offer
uh i grew up as a muslim abandoned
islamist practice and want to increase
my faith
severe doubt semester
not sure how to start
you know the best way to start
a poo
uh would be to find some brothers to
motivate you to to actually
become friends with brothers that you
consider to be practicing
and knowledgeable in some respects and
just to be around them your company the
company that you keep most of all not
people you sit on panels with i'm
talking about people who you actually
are friends with
those individuals will be the ones that
influence you
at the most so if you have that
encouragement from brothers and sisters
sorry i don't know if you're a sister
but from brothers if you're a brother
from brothers
then um
then you know then you can uh it's much
easier for you to get in to practicing
again okay and they can also give you
references and things like this
ahmadiyya's are not
part of his phone
yeah you got what i said there honest
man
it's not
i haven't i've seen jeffrey lang yeah i
don't really read his stuff
making hijra from the west what does
that even mean anymore
because even if you go to a muslim
majority country there's going to be
western influence right
um
we live in a global society now
it's not really anywhere you can go
i mean it's easier to live in a muslim
majority country don't get me wrong in
some respects
like eating and being around muslims and
massage it everywhere
but
when it comes to like certain things as
well it's also very difficult like
security is also
uh not as good in certain muslim
countries
um
you know
health and cleanliness is also not as
good in certain places i'm just being
frank
um
you know we need to up our game if we're
going to talk about hijrah we need to
actually provide reasons
to live in those countries right i mean
i'm not saying that our countries are
horrible per se i'm just saying that we
have we also don't have a lot of
opportunities economically and education
wise i mean we have too many too much of
our talent is being exported
into western nations because we're not
providing the educational opportunities
and work opportunities that
that
they need
you know
our our science like our scientists
should not be working for nasa
and and universities here in the united
states they should be working for us
in our countries but we're we're more
concerned with with you know other
things that we're not giving them those
opportunities
um
you know like like i said there's these
they're rich arabs in the uae for
example in princes and kings and have
like
unimaginable amounts of money that they
could be funding for science programs
for universities
to make us
on par if not better
than a lot of western institutions but
we're not doing it
why
why and then instead
our people our best our most talented
minds leave the country and then we
import europeans into our countries to
do all the work that
our own people should be doing right
this is this is backwards
that makes no sense
we want to talk about building the
caliphate returning to the caliphate we
can't even we're still borrowing
from westerners
like
what is this
it's like it's like a four-year-old
child who can't feed himself
you know acting like
like trying to be like yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna own my own house and have my
own family but you know i still need my
mommy to feed me it's like that's that's
essentially the mentality of the muslim
world right now
looks like the chat is slowing down
uh book recommendations i may do that
later i have a lot of books
so
multi-polar world with china i don't
know
i'm not necessarily afraid of china
becoming a powerhouse because it already
is but i am afraid of china becoming a
powerhouse at the same time
there's china is such a diverse
country
that anything really could go with the
way that that government is doing like
the people could i mean other countries
could be born from china at this point
it's it's a very complex area region and
i'm actually i'm legitimately scared
what their government is going to be
doing in the near future but at the same
time i don't know if the people per se
are going to follow suit
um
yes they are the chinese government's
oppressing the eucharist
and they're committing genocide right
now allah may allah protect the ugar
people and may allah punish the
oppressors
um at the same time though we also have
to consider that there are many chinese
people who are not involved in that and
aren't even
aware
like living in like the mountains and
stuff no idea what eggs going on
um
i think the homeless rate will increase
dramatically especially in the united
states because we have such
high living cost in our the expense of
food here a lot of people don't realize
those of you who don't live in the
united states we have a huge problem
with homelessness yes we have high
living standards and a lot of people
earn better than most people around the
world but here
like okay so let me give you example
when i wasn't living in malaysia for
seven years
i rarely saw a homeless person like
rarely
okay even the poorest people could feed
themselves
but here in the united states we have
people literally living on the streets
dying from cold
digging through trash cans to find
scraps of food they ca they're dying
from hunger
okay and they're they're everywhere
like not just one person every few miles
like there are times i remember i lived
in chicago
and during the winter time it got so
cold
that literally wallahi i saw this it was
almost it was so disgusting
one time i was driving down the road and
i saw a mile long
a mile long of homeless people
sleeping on the street huddled next to
each other for warmth
i didn't even realize there were that
many homeless people in this in the
whole city
like it looked like
a a train track of bodies
it was just it was hor it was horrible
and i've never seen that anywhere else
and they do tend to be minorities and
also veterans and uh old people and
people with disease like you know mental
illness etc
they all protect us from what's to come
the government
look at look at who we have as a
president in this country you want to
talk about the government doing stuff
come on
yeah and also medical care a lot of
people don't realize this
medical care in the united states is the
most expensive in the world
like their
cost of medicine here the cost of health
care is so absurd
that
there are people out there
who are i mean
they don't even go to the emergency room
because they can't afford it
like they would rather suffer in pain
and die
than have to live with paying those
bills
i remember i've told a lot of people but
i remember reading a story a couple
years back
where a man walked into a bank with a
fake gun
and he pointed and he tried to steal
a dollar
a dollar and then he just sat there
waiting for the police to come and when
the police came and arrest him they
asked him like why why did you hold up
this bank
trying to steal a dollar like what's
wrong with you are you okay are you
mentally unwell he's like
i have cancer and in prison health care
is free
that was legit legitimately
his reason
he wanted to be arrested to go to prison
because he needed health care
okay that's how bad it is in this
country
i know it's just one anecdote but it's
it's very bad
okay
so i think a lot of these questions are
kind of going back to the previous
discussion so please watch the earlier
video the earlier parts of this video
once again i do apologize for anything i
want to give my last thoughts here
um
i thank all of you uh sincerely from the
bottom of my heart for all your support
and and uh
over the years
i don't intend for this necessarily to
be my last video
however i do anticipate that
whatever
counter counter-refutation comes in my
way is going to be
full of slander
and um degradation
uh so you know this ship is already
going to be sinking
and um i'm going to be cancelled from
the scene anyway so it doesn't really
matter
but
i want you all to take from my
work take from my thoughts
uh some benefit
so that you can move on
and you can continue building something
better
in the dalla culture in this reputation
culture
and i want you to expect better from
your dies i want you to expect better
from yourselves and i want you to
to to
inculcate
the virtues of integrity and honor in
all of the things that you do even with
your enemies
i want you to be able to apologize even
to your enemies if you need to because
you
value truth
over your ego you value truth over your
hatred
and that is the only way we're ever
going to move forward as an ummah
so i ask if you please
if you're going to take an example from
me
learn from my mistakes
and learn from
my attempt at rectification
and i ask if you continue pleasing me
please make do offer me continue to make
a lot for me
and to and and make to offer yourselves
and to better yourselves
and better those around you make this
dawah seem
what it should be
exemplify the virtues that we are
supposed to exemplify
and just thank you in general
so
insha allah i will maybe give you an
update in the future
but uh in the meantime
i love you all for the sake of allah
and
may our struggle
be rewarded
so
take care
assalamu